your solo I love it okay so 16 years ago
I was on your show I remember with Kelly
I was actually your daughter's on the
same time and now you're on my show this
is like a full circle moment when I
heard that you were getting your show
and it was a daytime show I was like oh
that's fantastic just to see the way
you've grown and all the different
things that you've been doing with your
career and I'm like oh I wish I could be
on that show but they'll never ask me
because this is the it's a kind of
unwritten rule in TV that if you're in
the same kind of space in daytime and
there's another talk show on another
network they they don't like to promote
each other shows so let's say if I
wanted to go on another day time talk
show there's no way cuz they go no your
competition you're not coming here and
also there are a few people that get
celebrities and they say no you have to
come to my show first so there's all
these little laying or are always yeah
and then when you ask me I'm like oh my
god trust Kelly I love you do you
realize that you have broken the mold by
doing that I'm never never does it this
always happens to me like in music as
well they're always like surprise I hate
when I get tweets of like oh my god I
can't believe she's supported another
woman in music and I'm like I'm actually
more mad at the fact that you have to
say that it's been late to cross over
Lulu's different things together on
different people show a resume I can do
no I look what in speaking of the talk
though after this is like 10 seasons now
since season anyway I keep saying this
because it's true it's the only show
I've done that I've never got fired from
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my god you're literally one of my
favorite people in the plane and I can't
believe some would fight you're fired
because they can't handle it again I
can't handle the awesomeness they can't
handle it that's what I'm going with
well well stick with exactly that's what
I do in life I just filter everything
they're like you're an ugly troll and
I'm like I'm a beautiful Beyonce seasons
I'm curious cuz I I keep talking all
these hosts about you know their
favorite moments and yeah and I'm
wondering what's your favorite moment in
ten seasons there's a lot of seasons my
lord so well favorite people I know my
favorite people that I've been allowed
to interview is Elton John that's a band
Keanu Reeves
[Applause]
he's so game actually Ellen seems going
oh he he'll like for a laugh he'll do
anything he's he's so open to you know I
love this that's why I love you so much
I'm gonna keep saying it like a stalker
I'm sorry but were there ever any
moments because I have these moments on
tour that I had that didn't go so well
but did you ever have any moments on the
show that you're like that didn't go as
planned they used to get me to do
cooking segments and I have false nails
and I stick them on there the old you
know color with so much in common
I love cooking segments and then like
get this mince roll it up into a burger
and I'm rolling it up and there's a
couple of nails in the burger and I'm
like oh they'll never see it of course
you know like our color shows up and
Wolfgang didn't really like that kind of
television the unplanned and then I was
sat talking on the show and I'm like oh
there's something going on in my mouth
and my tooth fell out honestly I'm not
lying like in a cooking demo no shoe
John Redman goes to me in the break get
some super blue and put it back ad oh
what can I try this super glue and
everything now I'm super glue should go
in your mouth didn't even stick anywhere
oh and it says it sticks anything but it
doesn't stick T you needed like Gorilla
Glue or duct tape guerrilla corporate
doctor like to get it in there I love
that did you just keep during the show
oh yeah just hide
[Applause]
so you've done so many shows and I love
them all but do you ever do you ever you
ever gonna retire you love it you just
still love it yeah I I'm you know it's
like it gives me such joy sitting here
yeah this lot with you what I wouldn't
give up being able to meet amazing
people and somebody says you can't do it
anymore it would be like and then what
am I doing here
yeah you know I love that you find joy
in it I love it yeah that's why that's
why I continue and that's also why
you're like you've done a lot of things
you're telling me I do a lot of things
cuz I get bored with monotony but I love
people so I'm glad I just love watching
you on that voice having a go at
everyone I still want you to be a coach
on the voice because I have seen you on
another show and you are so fantastic or
fabulous as you say all the time I'm
seriously a stalker I've watched so many
but here's one thing I love that you did
it was actually I think it did it this
the beginning of this the talk this
season is you talked openly about
facelifts you talked openly because you
it almost makes it less taboo and less
of a topic if you if you do that's what
I love about Dolly Parton
she owns every bit of it she's like I
love that you do that because while some
people might not be comfortable that
some people are comfortable that and
that's where they they love to do it and
I love that you talk about it openly cuz
a lot of people don't and they're like I
haven't had anything done
this is just new cream lips everything I
live in deception you know it's like oh
please wait and is it hard cuz I'm
scared of stuff like I'm terrified like
I can get tattoos I have like 15 but the
thought of something I'm scared with
you're never scared you just go in and
you're like yeah I am I am yeah sure
because you know you could wake up and
look like Cyclops you never know
and like I had to sing where they lifted
up my mouth and then for the first like
week I'm like couldn't film um I
couldn't hardly feel my mouth now to be
honest with you
I couldn't find my candy answering
system sorry but he can't can he no man
like it was I had it was up at one side
and I look like Elvis and and all the
kids are nausea going why are you
snarling at me I'm like I'm not doing
anything but it was this it was going up
like my my mother had dental work done
one time and I felt so bad because it
literally her she couldn't feel it
because they numbed it yeah and we were
eating and there her spaghetti was
coming out of her mouth and I couldn't
tell her cuz I was laughing so hard and
she was getting so mad at me and then
she just kept going anyway I love you
for being open that's one of the reasons
why I love you I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this